what did you think about this ruling
it's a surprise it's a surprise on a
couple of different levels first there's
the size of the award it's about two
million dollars bigger than any award in
of this nature in the past second the
fact that it went for the gay family it
looked like early rulings might shift it
over to the Robin Thicke Pharrell
Williams side of things but the third
thing is is this shouldn't have come to
trial most suits of this nature are
settled before they get this far and
there are many suits of this nature
they're settled for share credit on the
publishing rights or they're settled for
a lump sum so what kind of precedents
does this set when we have a seven point
four million dollar price tag and it did
go to court well I think if I was in the
the music industry if I was in the
publishing side if I was on the label
side I would be preparing for a lot more
suits of this nature and it needs to be
said there are already a lot of suits of
this nature there are copyright lawyers
who say when a suit of this nature is
brought whether it is merit or not
sometimes it's just someone trying to
extort money out of songwriters and
producers I think that's a little
extreme some of these suits have merits
some don't we're going to see more of
them and I suspect we're going to see
people looking for more bigger subs what
was it about this that made it go to
jury to begin with it's a very good
question and of course I haven't spoken
to legal counsel on both sides so I
can't tell you if Pharrell Williams and
Robin Thicke's lawyers were unwilling to
settle or if the gay family was
unwilling to accept a settlement but
they were geared up for a fight for Rob
Williams and Robin Thicke tried to get a
peremptory judgment they tried to blow
this out of the water before a suit was
ever filed and once it got there it was
just fighting and how hard is it to
really prove I mean if you're listening
to something it kind of in the back your
brain inspires well I think if you were
listening to these two songs
back-to-back
it wouldn't be in the back of your brain
there's a real similarity here but
that's what makes this so interesting
the judge didn't want these tracks
played back-to-back he told the jury to
look at the compositional element in
other words to look at the sheet music
and that's when we thought it was going
to really lean towards the Thicke and
Pharrell Williams side last question the
music industry at large how can they
revamp best practices to kind of take
this out of well you know in the hip-hop
world where music is built off samples
the music industry they use experts to
listen to the tracks to identify the
samples and to say look I think we have
enough here that we need to go get this
cleared and I think we're going to see a
similar sort of thing just on original
compositions you don't have people
listening to say I think we may have an
issue here let's get ahead of this
before it's a problem